>>> Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome vice
president of engineering for Google, Vic Gundotra.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Well, good morning.
Good morning.
And hello.
On behalf of Google, let me extend a very
warm welcome to all 5,000 in attendance today,
as well as the many more thousands who are
watching our first-ever live streamcast of
this event on YouTube.com.
Thank you.
You know, it's hard to believe that this is
our third Google I/O.
It's not only our largest Google I/O, it's
the one that we sold out the fastest.
It even surprised us.
Within weeks of announcing this conference,
we sold out of this event two and a half months
in advance.
We think that speaks volumes about the level
of enthusiasm that you all have for this important
community event.
And at Google, we recognize how precious and
valuable your time is, and we're honored and
grateful that you have chosen to spend two
days here with us.
We hope you find this conference exciting
and really engaging, and we have a few surprises
for you as well.
Now, some of you may wonder, how did we name
this conference?
What does I/O stand for?
Three-plus years ago, when we first thought
about holding a developers' conference and
we thought about naming the event, we contemplated
multiple choices.
We wanted a name that, most importantly, embodied
the spirit of the Web, a spirit of collaboration.
Sometimes messy, but always fun.
A spirit of inclusiveness rather than exclusiveness.
A spirit of innovation and of openness.
And, of course, we wanted this event to appeal
to developers.
So we thought, what's the first thing a developer
learns to do when they begin to code?
Well, it's input and output.
That's I/O.
But I/O also stands for two of the most important
elements of our Web culture: Innovation in
the open.
Make no mistake about it, the Web is the most
important platform of our generation.
And because it's a platform controlled by
none of us, it's the only platform that truly
belongs to all of us.
And it's our job as a community to move that
Web forward.
And so you can imagine how pleased we were
last year at this conference to focus the
world's attention, the developer community's
attention, on an important standard, HTML5.
It was at this conference in this room last
year that you can see we first started driving
attention toward HTML5.
And events later on in the year continued
that momentum that we, as a community, started.
That huge spike is YouTube's adoption of HTML5.
That other spike is Apple's adoption.
I think it was a Steve Jobs late-night e-mail
or something.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: That last spike --
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Hey, we'll take support from
wherever we can get it.
That last spike included Microsoft's support
for HTML5.
As a community, working together, and collaboratively,
we can move the Web forward.
Of course, we recognize that we are far from
done.
We recognize that the Web has important challenges
that we need to address as a community.
How can we make the Web faster?
How can we make Web apps as discoverable as
you see, for example, in app stores?
How can we make it easier for developers to
monetize those applications?
And, finally, can we make the Web extend its
reach even to new form factors?
We hope to show you our proposed answers to
some of these questions at this conference.
And we're very much looking forward to your
feedback.
Of course, the Web is growing up.
It's all happening because we're working on
it together.
And we think this conference is an important
part of that process.
Before I hand off to our opening keynote speaker,
let me just make two housekeeping announcements.
The first announcement is, I hope you all
enjoyed the Android devices that we sent you
as part of registering.
[ Applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: If you have not already done
so, please go to the Android Marketplace and
download an application we specifically designed
for you at this conference, just do a search
on Google conference or Google I/O, and you'll
find this application.
This application will make it very easy for
you to make the best use of your time and
to really find the sessions that interest
you the most.
The second and last housekeeping note, tomorrow's
keynote will not start at 9:00 a.m.
It will start at 8:30 in the morning.
I know, that's early in the morning, particularly
for you developers.
But I promise you, you will not be disappointed.
We have more than one surprise tomorrow morning.
So have fun at the party tonight, but remember,
the fun starts at 8:30 tomorrow morning.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: All right.
With that, let me hand off to our opening
keynote speaker, who will carry the banner
of the open Web.
Please join me in welcoming Google vice president
of product management, Sundar Pichai.
[ Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai:
Thanks, Vic.
It's great to be here.
I'm going to be talking to you today about
HTML5, the incredible momentum we have, all
the new capabilities that are coming up, how
modern browsers are going to support these
APIs.
We will show you real-world examples.
We will invite application developers who
are building amazing experiences on top of
HTML5.
And, finally, we will have a couple of important
announcements on the way.
So let's get started.
First, as Vic mentioned, the Web is the most
important platform of our generation.
And from a user standpoint, people are spending
more of their time on the Web.
Compared to every other information medium
out there, the Web is more than double in
terms of the amount of time people spent in
the last five years.
Every other information medium has been the
same or has declined.
That's how important the Web is in users'
lives.
How are developers reacting to it?
We started taking a look at how applications
have been written since 1990.
Most of you are familiar with the popular
desktop applications: Microsoft Office, iTunes,
Skype, Photoshop.
The list goes on and on.
These are amazing applications which we all
use in our day-to-day lives.
The interesting thing, though, is, since 2004,
we can't come up with popular desktop applications,
outside of games and browsers, that are being
used by millions of users.
What happened in 2004?
It turned out it is the year in which Ajax
and the Web 2.0 revolution happened.
People started writing these applications
as Web applications, applications which you're
all very familiar with: GMail, Google Maps,
Twitter, Facebook, et cetera.
The world changed.
The Web changed from documents to applications.
And developers started reaching users by writing
Web applications instead of desktop applications.
So this is a powerful change.
It's a very important trend.
Given that, we need to make sure Web applications
can do everything that desktop applications
can do.
You're all very familiar with this.
Historically, desktop applications have had
full access to system capabilities.
So they could talk to the speaker, microphone,
camera.
They could access the file system, for example.
Web applications have been limited in what
they can do.
This is what the HTML5 work is all about.
We are working very hard as a community to
make sure all these capabilities show up in
the browser.
Let me give a few examples.
Most computers today ship with powerful GPUs.
How do you make sure Web applications can
access these graphics capabilities?
That's what Web GL and the graphics APIs are
all about.
Workers, it is about allowing Web applications
to access the multi-core CPUs present on the
computers.
There are APIs to access the local file system,
local storage, speaker, microphone, camera,
and the list goes on.
All this matters only if browsers support
these APIs.
So let's take a look at how we are doing there.
About 24 months ago, this had just gotten
under way.
There was pioneering work here by Firefox,
Safari, Opera, and Chrome didn't even exist
then.
So this is about 24 months ago, and it had
just gotten under way.
Let's fast forward to where we were last year
during Google I/O.
You can see the momentum was there.
Set of APIs being implemented in all modern
browsers, including Chrome.
So the progress was very exciting.
So where do we expect to be by the end of
this year?
As you can see, all the major APIs are going
to be present in all modern browsers.
So --
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: So U.S. developers can bank
on these APIs being present in the browsers
when users reach your applications.
Another important trend is mobile.
All of you are carrying a smart phone here
today.
The interesting thing there is, the smart
phones all are connected with capable browsers.